Russia has launched a number of missile
strikes across Ukraine killing at least
one person in the southern city of mikev
two people were injured in keev parts of
the capital have been left without power
after falling debris damaged power lines
Rob McBride is joining us from Ukraine's
Capital ke to talk to us more about the
latest Russian
strikes yeah that's right air strikes
being reported across uh across Ukraine
this Wednesday morning the alert was
first raised in the early hours of the
morning when a large number of Russian
war planes were detected taking off from
uh airfields in Russia and then sure
enough at first light we started to get
reports of the first strikes here in ke
there were around four loud explosions
with several locations uh being reported
hit probably the most serious has been
an apartment Block in the south of the
city in fact we've been watching a pole
of smoke for the past hour or so on the
a few kilometers to the south of us here
which appears to have been that
apartment block with reports of seven
floors of that building being on fire
and several people being injured and
hospitalized but other cities have been
hit in the Northeast har has been hit
once again and also reports of strikes
in the very far west of the country
around Lviv it it seems as though a lot
of the weapons being used were cruise
missiles which can often be set on a
very complicated Meandering course to
try to uh confound confuse air defenses
in fact a couple of these missiles are
reported to have been heading towards
the Polish border but then turned back
towards the city of Lviv all of this
comes as the parliament here in uh in
keev is uh is debating new legislation
to try to increase the pace of
mobilization amid growing awareness here
that there simply Aren't Enough soldiers
to fight this
war with his country in a deadlocked war
and in need of recruits 50 5-year-old
Mika has decided to put on a uniform and
pick up a
gun well the time has come we need to
end this the young people don't fully
understand their time will come too he's
joining the azof volunteers a unit known
for its farri fuse and Ultra nationalism
that says it has no problem attracting
new
recruits we need to communicate with
people not to intimidate them everyone
will have to fight sooner or later so
there has to be a reserve but nationally
Ukraine seems to be suffering War
fatigue when the fullscale war broke out
tens of thousands of men eagerly
volunteered to fight but two years on
with the growing realization that it
won't be over any time soon that
enthusiasm has faded and many of those
first volunteers still on the front
lines are simply
exhausted legislation is being debated
that would reportedly swell the ranks of
the military by up to half a million but
that would still mean soldiers serving
now not being discharged for three years
and many families who regularly Hold
Street protests believe that's unfair we
want demobilization after 18 months
there are some of us who carry the
burden of this war while there are
others here at home who are getting used
to the war and ignoring it with Russia
still managing to find waves of new
recruits for its assaults there's a
growing Fe in from these protesters
their husbands and Sons will be lucky to
make it home again Rob McBride Al jazer
Keith the air raid alarm has been lifted
here within the past hour here in the
capital Kev but there are we're still
getting reports of damage around the
country also from the southern city of
mikf where Shahid drones were used we're
getting reports of damage to uh
dwellings there to properties and also
more injuries all right thank you
McBride reporting from
keev